das hier ist mein youtube kanal sowie
wir ihn normalerweise kennen allerdings
war ich ja youtube nicht erst seit ein
paar wochen und ein paar monaten sondern
tatsächlich jetzt schon seit fünf
beziehungsweise fast schon sechs jahren
und da habe ich mich einfach mal gefragt
wieso eigentlich dieser normale kanal
hier vor mir heutzutage aus quasi fünf
jahre vorher und dafür bin ich mal
wieder auf der website wayback machine
gelandet das ist nämlich ein internet
archiv also eine website auf der man
andere website url eingeben kann und
diese website zeigt eine man wie diese
urls vor einigen jahren ausgesehen haben
ich hab so ein video hier schonmal
hochgeladen haben wo ich mir auch schon
mal einen kanal angeguckt habe aber
diesmal mit speziellem auf die
kommentare geben die früher auf meinen
kanal geschrieben wurden youtube.com
crafter wir können jetzt einfach mal auf
browser history klicken das dauert jetzt
ein ganz kleinen moment und dann sehen
wir hier schon 2011 und davor wurde
nichts eingereicht aber 2012 wenn wir da
jetzt mal drauf klicken
sehen wir schon dass diese website 2012
foto gespeichert auf jeden fall sind
dass sie jetzt so alles die daten an
diese website hier nochmal gespeichert
wurde das erste datum ist der sechzehnte
februar 2012 da wurden mich zwei
slapshots gemacht ich krieg da jetzt
einfach mal drauf und jetzt wird mir
nämlich angezeigt wie main kanal quasi
vor fünf jahren aussah also 2012 von
2017 fünf jahre zurück oh mein gott
freunde es lädt hier gerade ich weiß es
ich schon mal auf so etwas reagiert habe
aber ich finds design hamann design
früher konnte man seinen kanal halt noch
so mega krass anpassen was das design
und alles mögliche angeht und alter ich
hatte immer noch so einen livestream
booms hier oben extra reingepackt wir
habe ich immer wenn ich meine leistung
gemacht habe was tatsächlich sehr sehr
selten der fall war eigentlich habe ich
mein design hier verändern und hab mir
live stream doppelpunkt online dann
quasi hin gepackt und das war total dumm
weil am tag vielleicht zehn leute auf
meine mama kanal waren aber eigentlich
war das hier megageil man konnte hier so
drauf kriegen da kann man auf irgendein
video einmal von hier draufklicken da
kann man zu meinem facebook hier wurde
früher immer so das video angezeigt was
man sehen wollte das hier war meine
video beschreibung hallöchen mein name
ist lukaku war teilweise dieser hallo
mein name ist luca begrüße und mein name
ist sogar bin noch 15 von mir gehört
dieser chaotischen kanal wenn du mich
etwas fragen willst dann schreib doch
bitte einen kanal kommentar und diese
kanal kommentare werden wir jetzt mal
durchgehen hier hat man noch so die
reset activity also was man so in
letzter zeit gut gemacht hat auf der
plattform habe ich zb ein video von
alberto kommentiert damals miterlebt
mein gott da sieht man dass sie noch 15
mann an ich habe gedacht die
vergangenheitsform von leaf ist leistet
sehr gut luca wenn wir jetzt nämlich
einfach mal runter scrollen sehen wir
hier schon so ein paar preise die ich
damals irgendwie hatte
platz 79 moss tipps krautheim comedian
germany und so weiter und so fort
und dann sieht mich hier nämlich schon
channel kommen kannst mal einen download
link von der place in minecraft machen
wäre cool da die musik cool
ja auch schon früher konnten die leute
kein deutsch und das war gerade auch
kein richtiges deutsch dragon kriegen
schreibt bin wieder da ich wünsche dir
ein erholsamer guten 8 luca laden mal
wieder es tiefe island hoch benutzt du
meine musik noch wurde auch gesagt hatte
luca ich bin noch nicht sehr lange dabei
und haben ein paar fragen an die kann
ich auch sky block spielen lass dir
runter früher war skype blog so ein
riesending auf youtube und dadurch dass
auch gezockt hey congo after ich bin neu
hier kannst du folge vier von s cup
island reinstellen also grammatik und
rechtschreibung wurde ganz groß
geschrieben damals meine vorgeschlagenen
kanäle früher waren gamestar warum
gamestar hits mit hatte ich
vorgeschlagen diener austria lps markov
wenig shuffle wasserkanister game kraft
minecraft backe dvl minecraft und skate
aid to germany ich hatte zu dem
zeitpunkt einfach 11.000 abonnenten
oh mein gott walther das ist ja das ist
so tragen das ist so wie wenn man ein
elternteil ist und man sieht gerade so
die ersten schritte des eigenen kindes
so nicht krank wie das kind geboren
wurde aber sowieso ein meilenstein so
dass es versteht ihr was ich meine das
ist gerade voll die keine ahnung von
emotional für mich
[Musik]
die kompletten aufruf auf alle videos
die ich zu dem zeitpunkt hochgeladen
hatte waren 1,8 millionen ihr müsst euch
das mal vorstellen mittlerweile habe ich
eben diese 800 bis 900 millionen aufrufe
das ist einfach so das 500 fache aber
wir schauen uns jetzt mal die kommentare
noch ein bisschen weiter an ich habe
jetzt einfach mal auf nic
[Musik]
ach nein das lied nicht website ist ja
nur gesichert worden quasi von diesem
stand wo diese kommentare da drauf sind
und nicht von ja nicht von den anderen
seiten das war so krank früher man
konnte einfach alles anpassen
ich hatte hier so pipa drauf ich konnte
hier unten sogar noch facebook und
twitter verlinken aber wir gehen wir
zurück wieder zu way back maschinen 2012
dürfen uns da nichts mehr an wir gehen
jetzt mal zu jahr 2013 irgendwo in die
mitte hier in den juni und trinken auf 8
juni drauf also seinen kanal im jahr
2013 aus wir sehen schon hier oben der
banner und so das ist noch relativ
gleich zur heutigen zeit jähnichen
kanäle sehen heute ein bisschen anders
aus
related channels und so weiter und so
fort dass sie war damals oder staub
video mein gott freunde da ist gerade
das megaprojekt gelaufen und da gab es
doch diese 301 hughes sperre alter was
geht ab und das war auf jeden fall eine
kranke zeit früher
dann hatte ich hier die playlist
minecraft megaprojekt da meine ersten
reihe live videos alter das hat er so
langsam gerade alles angefangen dass ich
mich gezeigt habe wir haben bei
minecraft fakes das hatte ich früher
noch minecraft learn guide sogar genannt
minecraft mods die ich vorgestellt habe
mannschaft zieht main kanal war früher
wirklich kompletten minecraft als das
noch aktuell war ich meine mannschaft
ist immer noch aktuell aber ich finde
wirklich dadurch dass und jetzt mal ein
bisschen auf das thema minecraft zu
kommen warum ich das in letzter zeit
nicht so häufig hochladen
für mich hat es einfach ein bisschen den
faden verloren weil so viel hinzugefügt
wurde für mich war minecraft früher so
egal das ist minecraft und leute haben
aus den wenigen möglichkeiten die es gab
sehr viel gemacht man mittlerweile hat
sich mo yan beziehungsweise microsoft
alles möglich genommen was er schon gibt
jpg style und alles mögliche und keine
ahnung was und hat das alles zusammen in
das normale mannschaft gemacht und es
wurde mir irgendwie ein bisschen zu viel
also ich habe meinen kraft eigentlich
nur mal gefallen weil zu simpel war aber
dass die wahl auf jeden fall der kanal
im jahr 2013 ich weiß habe ich jetzt auf
discussion klicken kann um dann mal zu
sehen dadurch übrigens 172000 abonnenten
dann loading content
wahrscheinlich konnte glauben wir
befinden uns hier zum jahr 2014 und
gehen jetzt hier einfach mal ans ende
zum beispiel auf den 6 november und
schauen jetzt mal wie meine youtube
kanal seite im
geht das denn nicht man 2015 wird wohl
nicht für krass gewesen sei nicht jetzt
mal den august 2015 also ich glaube dass
man als nicht zum krassen unterschied
merkt wie so kriege ich die ganze diesen
cappella also ich bin jetzt hier auf der
seite angekommen
das ist mein kanal im jahr 2015 mitte
2015 der baut sich gerade noch so ein
bisschen auch wir sehen ich hatte da
fast eine million abonnenten die habe
ich zum beispiel ein entschuldigungs
video hochgeladen hatte ich meine
freundin hochgeladen
minecraft com on command zwar dennoch
aktuell an ter mario kempes die cetera
laden jetzt gerade nicht so krass also
das war auf jeden fall mein kanal hier
im jahr 2015 dann wenn wir oben jetzt
einmal auf 2016 klicken dann braucht er
auf jeden fall erstmal wieder auch nie
das und ab
und wahrscheinlich hätte ich genauso
viele abonnenten auch 2016 aber das ist
schon irgendwie 2015 das ist so ein zwei
jahre her gerade mal hatte ich nicht mal
eine million und jetzt bin ich bei
irgendwie 2,6 oder so voll krank also
ich weiß es noch nicht als zahl aber ich
sage halten die danke deswegen danke
2016 müssen wir uns jetzt glaube ich
nicht mehr angucken
das ist ja relativ gleich die 2017 aber
was mich mal interessieren würde wenn
ich einfach nur youtube.com eingeben
würde youtube.com seht ihr schon wurde
enorm oft gesichert viel häufiger als
meiner seite ist natürlich auch klar
youtube bisher viel beliebter so wie
alles viel beliebter ist als ich aber
hier sehen wir zum beispiel youtube
wurde das erste mal am 28 april 2005
gesichert da kriegen wir es einfach mal
drauf als wenn youtube vor zwölf jahren
so außerdem guckt euch das an hier so
home favorite messages videos mein
profil und dann kommt man sich hier also
noch mal anmelden hat dann hier quasi
seine autos gesehen es ist halt schon
krank ich jetzt mal einfach vor 1 jahr
2008 und guck mal wie es da aus st ich
habe youtube glaube ich kennengelernt
beziehungsweise das erst mal von der
plattform gehört im jahr 2010 oder soja
das war schon relativ spät eigentlich da
war es dann auch so dass ich dann quasi
die relativ zeitgleich dann auch mit
videos selber angefangen habe weil ich
diese option cool für oh mein gott
youtube hat gerade geladen im jahr 2008
alter guckt euch das an man das hier
oben haben die noch beibehalten mit home
video channels community und upload aber
hier unten sieht alles anders aus als es
gab schon immer diese features videos
aber hey wie krank an dass das oh mein
gott youtube mobile what's new alter bin
jetzt einfach mal in das jahr 2011
gegangen wo ich glaube ich mit youtube
videos angefangen habe da sei die
plattform nicht so aus da kann ich nicht
auch noch daran erinnern das war nämlich
so bei mord popular wird quasi alles
immer nur das beste videos aus der
jeweiligen aus der jeweiligen kategorie
angezeigt ja trends
ja auch schon und ja alter ist aber ihre
wie sich alles so krank entwickelt hat
man das war es jetzt der familie meine
damen und herren es euch gefallen hat
das gerne mal ein leichter und schaut
mal youtube in die kommentare
wenn ihr gerade auf youtube seite sonst
würde ich jetzt sagen meine damen und
herren
die austro das wasser das war's jetzt
ihr vom video hier können jetzt hier mal
den kanal abonnieren oder hier unten
meinen job ausschenken ihr findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]